hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
like my hearty and I'm Jake Decker and
last week we talked about divinity
original sin to a kind of old-school ish
computer RPG that everybody's been
talking about lately an isometric kind
of sequel to obviously divinity original
sin one from Larian Studios in Belgium
this game is awesome you and I both like
it yeah I haven't played nearly as much
as you I've only probably played ten
hours across three characters now cuz
I've been reroll in characters feel like
I don't like I did that start over I'm
still trying to figure things out
whatever lasses have you been using I've
done re like races and clouds beyond
barbarian is the skeleton I think
barbarians a class the one with the axe
I've been there's a lot there's like 16
or so I've been the Archer an elf Archer
and then I've been a human just a
warrior the other Ranger were you
talking about a ranger yeah those ones I
was almost gonna die did the polymorph
you can turn your arm into a tentacle
hit people also turn into a bowl in
charge of people that's pretty cool but
then I've been like upgrading the skills
I need to actually get new skills sorry
upgrading the traits I need to get new
skills and that's been fun cuz I'm I
like whole bars filled up I'm almost on
to my second ability bar but yeah for
people who have played this game so far
you know it's a very very dense very
deep RPG a lot Baldur's Gate Baldur's
Gate to almost like pillars of eternity
kind of I would say like torment tides
of numenera which was last year that was
a little more text-based but in general
yeah like this actual this role-playing
game that you know actually lets you
roleplay which is kind of and you know
we tossed around the the term
role-playing game so much now because
duties have RPG progression yeah so like
The Witcher 3 people in the comments
were saying it's not really an RPG it's
an action RPG I'm like but that's I'd
still considered a Witcher an RPG not in
the sense that divinity is yeah I think
with the video games people think of
RPGs as a game where you I mean at least
commonly people think of RPGs as a game
where you level up improve your
character
grow different skills but we're talking
about something differently with this
video we're talking about a game that
lets you actually step in the shoes of a
character that you created that you can
kind of you can fill in a lot of those
areas that are left blank it's not like
you're playing as Geralt who is a
defined character and has these beliefs
which you can you can maneuver within
those
definitions but this actually lets you
pick your own character and choose your
own path based on that kind of like
Skyrim or reminiscent of like pen and
paper RPGs from back they've done yeah
that's exactly what they were based on
but as always in our off week episode we
do have QA we want to get to we had some
comments as people seem to like this
episode there's been a lot being said
about divinity original sin too so we
were trying to figure out what to talk
about and I figured it was a really cool
approach to player choice in you know a
genre that I felt has been a little bit
lacking lately but then that's not even
true because you look around like I said
torment pillars of eternity and then
pillars of eternity to is on the horizon
it's just like they're they've been
harder to find and I love that divinity
original sin 2 is getting so much
recognition because I think it deserves
it but yeah you want to get to the
questions Jake you want to do actually
I'll do the first why don't you yeah you
do the first one all right so this is
more of like kind of a callback I guess
so I was talking with my video about how
I have an undead character the skeleton
who essentially because I was
role-playing I just accepted that he was
gonna keep screwing up and missing shots
and saying the wrong thing to people so
I was like oh I'll just embrace the
whole like idiot role so limey lesson on
YouTube said so you're saying that you
accidentally role played as papyrus the
Skellington which is kind of made me
laugh because if you play it undertale
and you know who that is
it's essentially the skeleton one of the
skeleton brothers that you encounter
he's supposed to be evil but he keeps
trying to be arched but he's just really
dumb and keeps helping you solve puzzles
that he lays out for you and it just
becomes comic relief along the way so I
figured I'd put that in here because I
just I know I recently played undertale
and that was a great comment limy thank
you for the for the call back to you
another game Jake knew I'll do this next
one alright said it free seven eight
three says great video truly informative
and easy to understand I do like the
references to baldur's gate Witcher 3
and MEA Mass Effect Andromeda my only
worry will be do you think divinity 2 is
maybe a bit too slow for this newer
generation of PC players I yes and no I
think as as someone who primarily only
played on console and just recently got
a PC
divinity to is definitely overwhelming
and kind of slow and I can see how that
would be a turn-off for a lot of people
in my situation however I think part of
it was because we gave it a 10 I was
like alright I need to really play more
of this game and the more I played the
more I loved it so yes I think that
could be an issue because it is much
slower there's a lot more to it however
I think people who do stick with it will
find I will get a lot out of it yeah I
would say I grew up with RPGs and kind
of my brother always had a PC I was
playing on but you know like in my early
20s and kind of late teens I was
primarily on consoles so I missed out on
things I would have loved to play then I
had to go back to Baldur's Gate 2 was
incidentally the last like true RPG I
think I played before I got back into
them and like 5 or 10 years after that
but I do think this will be slow if
you're not used to these kind of games
again we gave it 10 which means it's
essential which means everybody should
try it but I think the more you play the
more you realize that it's in the
details and the moment-to-moment kind of
stuff that you actually will find the
joy and like I honestly could not tell
you that much about what's going on in
the overarching story I know there's
essentially you're essentially trying to
ascend to godhood you know one of you
you're selected to go to godhood and
like only one of you can so it starts to
create cool betrayals between you and
your partners and that's not really
spoiler that's like people talk about
the interviews I won't go in further in
depth but it's the character
interactions it's these random people I
meet it's a holy [ __ ] I didn't know I
could do this with this attack or I
didn't know this person would react this
way because I'm an undead skeleton like
I love pulling off my hood and then like
kids people will just run away then
sprinting in the other direction when
they realize I'm an undead I also think
one thing too is that this game is fully
voiced which sounds little but I think I
think that goes a long way so impressive
for how much dialogue there is yeah and
all the voice acting at least that I've
come across is really good yeah which
definitely goes a long way because I I
don't mind reading in games I'm fine
with that but after a while especially
with that much dialogue I feel like it
would start to mm-hmm get old but with
that like you just click past you hear
what they say click past and it's it's
very entertaining yeah and
I do think it's not like people who are
used to Mass Effect's or Witcher 3 and
consider that they're the most RPG ish
game that they'll play we'll definitely
find the slow I think but you know if
you're one of those people watching this
and wondering if you should get into it
people been tweeting at us since the
last episode saying oh I picked this
game up on your recommendation it took a
little bit to get into but now I'm just
hooked and that's kind of been a few
people in the office who weren't
traditionally in to see RPGs as well
they're saying oh sure I'm not used to
this isometric kind of you know party
based just emergent gameplay kind of
thing with an actual role-playing game
and they're loving it and I highly
encourage everybody to try it if it's
slow just give it a chance it'll start
picking up I think it'll still be it's
not gonna be like super action-packed
but you will get into a more fun combat
and get more abilities and start to
really see how all these threads are
kind of unraveling certain parts of the
story and it's fantastic cool so thank
you for your comment on YouTube all
right last one question Ultima
Underworld was one of the most important
RPGs until this day one of the best in
the way offered the player freedom to
create their own narrative like an RPG
should I'm curious why you did not
mention Ultima at the beginning of this
video I seen many people forget it
that's a great call out I didn't forget
about it maybe in this video I did but
we did a whole thing about yeah yeah so
maybe that's a result of so yeah we did
we did a documentary series on Arkane
studios and how I immersive Sims which
is like this annoyingly come it's just
this annoying kind of inside baseball
term I'm sure a lot of people know it
but for RPGs that kind of put you in
this cohesive world and then let you
kind of toy around with the mechanics in
ways that you're kind of like doing
trial and error and just like
experimenting with it system shock
system shop - Ultima Underworld was like
the first one pray more recently
Dishonored - definitely outsider arcane
all the stuff they're doing even shadow
of mordor kind of has that with the
Nemesis system its focus on emerging
gameplay and seeing how these systems
interact I would honestly call that game
more of an immersive sim because for the
same reason I don't think you're getting
into your character as much in Ultima
Underworld you're improving your
character but it's like Jake said you're
not really at least when I played all
the underworld a long time ago and from
what I remember of it I was not really
role-playing I was more exploring the
world
and then using its systems to try to
figure out what to do rather than saying
what would my character do which is what
I do in divinity and torment and pillars
of eternity but it is definitely an
important game in RPGs because that was
one of the first games to put you in a
3d cohesive world that wasn't just
isometric right it was uh it was from
Looking Glass Studios back with Paul new
wrath dug church war inspector came on
and they all wanted to make those kind
of games because they grew up loving
them you're sorry they want to make
those kind of games because I realized
what 3d could do and more inspectors
like holy [ __ ] this is huge why are more
people not getting on this and then of
course they were going to make System
Shock and Ken Levine would come on for
System Shock 2 started this whole legacy
of things that led to like gone home
shame is black Lee left Looking Glass to
go start the original Xbox he pitched it
to Bill Gates in the room and said you
need to have a video game console and
it's it's a hugely important game I'm
glad you mentioned it rayray for on
YouTube and I like I said we also if you
want to look more into that we have a
three-part documentary series called
I'll link it at the end of this video ok
cool
yeah an arcade studios and how their
legacy comes from looking glass in those
I don't know JQ is there any other RPGs
that I didn't mention I know like
obviously you're a huge Mass Effect fan
you did a sadist party instead of that
was pretty funny people are commenting
on how ugly Baldwin Shepherd was in this
that was not my Shepard in last episode
I was Jakes blame him that's not my
Shepherd either we did this show on
games but also you can check out sort of
plug all this which is basically just a
playthrough of Mass Effect 2 and 3 of
just trying to basically break the game
kill everybody except Shepherd
except it's funny you should watch it
but anyway in terms of like games you
don't I like games the I think the
biggest game for me that kind of
scratched that role-playing it's that I
had never really had was when I first
played oblivion yeah I never played
Baldur's Gate I didn't play Baldur's
Gate 2 I haven't played I mean Tech I'll
blow but I don't know if that yeah I
mean that's an action RPG exactly
stemmed from games like this yeah but I
think this was divinity 2 was the first
real C RPG that I've ever played but I
think the first time I got that feeling
was with open
vn just cuz that that did exactly what
you were saying you start the game as
someone in prison basically the game
sets you up like just start over it like
begin a new life whatever you pick your
character make him however you want and
then him or her however you want and
then just kind of go out in the world
and I think I was like maybe fifteen or
sixteen when that game came out and I
just like did not do the story decided I
want to be a thief did the thief guilt
like met grey fox or whatever his name
was and then like alright I'm sick of
this and doing something else it was it
was cool I mean I love that feeling of
video games which I I don't think you
necessarily get not even in something
like Mass Effect Mass Effect is still
like a very direct path to the end yet I
can kind of choose different points same
with Witcher one of my favorite games of
all time which I love that game well but
right witcher 3 wild town which i I love
that game but still you are playing as
Geralt yeah and and I do think like
you're talking about oblivion I think
going out to Skyrim I think that game is
obviously like it's more mainstream than
a lot of these we're talking about you
know not to be I'm not being an elitist
RPG I'm saying I think it's factual that
that game sold a ton it's coming to see
everyone re-released on ps4 Xbox one PC
I think that game is impressive because
of how it brought this more traditional
role-playing game to such a wide
audience and I don't think it gets
enough credit for that but yeah I mean
I'll be playing Skyrim and I still play
it from time to time I'm gonna play it a
lot of mice which I you you know you you
make this character I'll make like a
wood elf and I'll focus on alchemy
archery one-handed stealth and like
conjuring because that's the character I
create in my head I could use to edit
weapons to start power ranking like you
know like I get to level 40 and I really
like two-handed it's one of the ones I
haven't upgraded I could start using
that but it wouldn't make sense for the
character so it doesn't feel as fun
because I'm not role-playing and that's
why divinity is so great even with like
the support characters who I didn't even
create they I'm like okay well the red
prints should probably not be a part of
this private conversation because he's
gonna screw it up somehow because he's
so diplomatic and so proud and like vain
and Sabeel she might just straight-up
kill this person because I have no idea
how many people she has beef with turns
out there's a lot and she keeps screwing
me over but I don't want to reload this
save and I think that's the mark of a
great RPG obviously you're always f
fiving so to be safe in any RPG you
should be saving a lot Skyrim is also a
chief example but the fact that I'm not
reliving saves as often as I might
another RPG I'm just rolling with the
punches is why I love divinity original
sin too and it's a great game I'm gonna
keep playing it in between everything
else and hopefully finish it up we are
kind of stepping into the next episode I
don't want to tease it too much but I
will tell you the games that we're gonna
talk about and maybe you can kind of
infer what the topic will be cop hat is
the main one if you've been paying
attention to these like debates swirling
around that game shadow of war which
reviews just went up Thursday if you're
watching this on Sunday and the evil
within to which by the time we publish
episode 16 evolve into will have been
out for two days there's a common thread
between all three games that we want to
talk about at least I'm assuming with
the evil it into which I haven't played
yet but the other two I have you been
playing cop head we're gonna we're gonna
talk about those games and then tie them
all together in a way that hopefully
provides a good maybe not argument on my
part but I sparked some debate and
questions in the comments which is what
we're always looking for yeah as always
in these Q&A episodes we love your input
as we these questions can attest to we
love comments you know like criticisms
just like suggestions for other games is
always like one of the best things you
can give us someone had suggested I try
out
pillars of eternity too when it comes
out so I'm looking forward to playing
that and yeah we will be back next week
as always with episode 16 and we'll see
you next week thank you
[Music]